DOWN WITH CHIEF POLITICAL
CORRESPONDENT DANA BASH FOR HER
FIRST INTERVIEW SINCE THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT' DECISION.
>> THERE WILL BE WOMEN WHO HAVE
BABIES WHO DON'T HAVE THE MEANS
TO SUPPORT THE BABIES.
WILL THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ACT
AT ALL TO INCREASE SUPPORT
THERE?
>> I'M SO GLAD YOU RAISE THAT
POINT BECAUSE I AM GOING TO SAY
THIS.
AND HERE IS THE ABJECT, OBVIOUS
HYPOCRISY.
THOSE PEOPLE WHO SAY THEY DO NOT
WANT TO ALLOW A WOMAN TO CHOOSE
TO MAKE THE DECISION WITH HER
PRIEST, WITH HER RABBI, WITH HER
PASTOR, THAT INSTEAD, THE
GOVERNMENT IS GOING TO INTERFERE
AND MAKE THE DECISION FOR HER.
THOSE SAME PEOPLE ARE THE ONES
WHO VOTED AGAINST THE EXTENSION
OF THE CHILD-TAX CREDIT.
THE SAME ONES WHO VOTED AGAINST
A TAX CUT FOR FAMILIES TO PAY
FOR CHILDCARE.
THE SAME ONES WHO ARE VOTING
AGAINST PAID-FAMILY LEAVE.
THE SAME ONES WHO VOTE AGAINST
PUTTING RESOURCES INTO PUBLIC
SCHOOLS.
I JUST -- I SAID I WAS DOING
WORK ON MATERNAL MORTALITY.
WE ARE PUSHING TO SAY THAT, FOR
EXAMPLE, MEDICAID SHOULD BE
EXTENDED FOR POSTPARTUM CARE
FROM 2 TO 12 MONTHS.
THESE ARE THE SAME PEOPLE WHO
REJECT THE NOTION OF MEDICAID.
>> CAN THE PRESIDENT DO ANY OF
WHAT YOU JUST TALKED ABOUT WITH
HIS PEN, WITHOUT CONGRESS?
>> WE HAVE, AS A DEMOCRACY,
INVESTED IN CONGRESS AN
INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF POWER.
AND SPECIFICALLY, THE POWER TO
CREATE LAWS.
AND SO, WE ARE GONNA REQUIRE AND
DEPEND ON CONGRESS TO SEE THIS
THROUGH, WHICH MEANS WE DO NEED
TO HAVE THE NUMBERS IN CONGRESS
WHO ARE WILLING TO SAY THEY
STAND FOR SUPPORTING WOMEN IN
EVERY WAY INCLUDING WOMEN AND --
AND MEN AS PARENTS AND ALL THE
COSTS OF BEING A PARENT.
>> SO LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT THAT.
YOU ARE SAYING NOW THE PRESIDENT
SAID THAT THIS FALL, ROE IS ON
THE BALLOT.
BUT WHAT DO YOU SAY TO
DEMOCRATIC VOTERS WHO ARGUE,
WAIT A MINUTE.
WE WORKED REALLY HARD TO ELECT A
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT AND VICE
PRESIDENT.
>> YEP.
>> DEMOCRAT-LED HOUSE.
A DEMOCRAT-LED SENATE.
DO IT NOW.
>> BUT DO WHAT NOW?
WHAT NOW?
I MEAN, WE NEED -- LISTEN, WE
STEBDED THE CHILD TAX CREDIT.
>> WHEN I SAY DO IT NOW, I MEAN,
ACT LEGISLATIVELY TO MAKE
ABORTION RIGHTS LEGAL.
>> WE WE FEEL THE SAME WAY.
IT -- DO IT NOW, CONGRESS NEEDS
TO DO IT NOW IN TERMS OF
PERMANENTLY PUTTING IN PLACE A
CLEAR INDICATION THAT IT IS THE
LAW OF THE LAND THAT WOMEN HAVE
THE ABILITY AND THE RIGHT TO
MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR
REPRODUCTIVE CARE AND THE
GOVERNMENT DOES NOT HAVE THE
RIGHT TO MAKE THOSE DECISIONS
FOR A WOMAN.
>> SO ONE OF THE WAYS YOU CAN DO
IT OBVIOUSLY.
ONE OF THE ONLY WAY THAT IS
LEGISLATIVELY PROCEDURALLY
POSSIBLE IS DOING AWAY WITH THE
FILIBUSTER ON THIS ISSUE.
PRESIDENT BIDEN TOLD MY
COLLEAGUE ANDERSON COOPER HE
WOULD BE OKAY WITH ELIMINATING
THE FILIBUSTER TO PASS VOTING
RIGHTS AND QUOTE MAYBE MORE.
WOULD YOU SUPPORT ELIMINATING
FILIBUSTER?
>> RIGHT NOW, GIVEN THE CURRENT
COMPOSITION OF THE SENATE, VOTES
AREN'T THERE.
>> THAT IS YOUR BULLY PULPIT TO
SAY, YES, I SUPPORT IT?
>> WELL, HERE IS THE THICK.
I UNDERSTAND WHAT -- WHY YOU ARE
ASKING THE QUESTION IS BUT THE
REALITY OF IT IS WE DON'T GET TO
REALLY ANSWER THAT IN TERMS OF
WILL IT HAPPENS OR NOT IF WE
DON'T HAVE THE NUMBERS IN THE
SENATE.
AND THAT'S WHY I KEEP COMING
BACK TO THE IMPORTANCE OF AN
ELECTION THAT IS ONLY 130-ODD
DAYS AWAY BECAUSE IT REALLY DOES
MATTER.
I SIT AS VICE PRESIDENT FOR THE
SENATE.
I WAS IN THE SENATE FOR FOUR
YEARS REPRESENTING STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND IF YOU DON'T HAVE
THE VOTES, YOU CAN'T MOVE
ANYTHING.
WE HAVE SEEN COUNTLESS EXAMPLES,
SADLY, OF THAT.
THIS SENATE, IN THE CURRENT
COMPOSITION WOULD NOT PASS
VOTING RIGHTS LEGISLATION.
I SAT IN THE CHAIR WHEN THE
WOMEN'S HEALTH ACT WAS ON THE
FLOOR FOR A VOTE AND DIDN'T HAVE
THE VOTES TO GET IT PASSED.
ON THE ISSUE OF ROE,
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE SO THE
NUMBERS AREN'T THERE.
BUT WE CAN'T DE-EMPHASIZE SNIFG
DANCE OF THAT.
>> BUT AS THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE SFLAT, DO YOU HAVE A
POSITION -- I KNOW YOU DON'T
HAVE A VOTE BUT DO YOU HAVE A
POSITION ON WHETHER THE
FILIBUSTER SHOULD BE ELIMINATED?
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT HAS
SPOKEN ON THAT.
IS THAT WHERE HE WAS LEAVING THE
DOOR OPEN TO?
>> I THINK HE HAS BEEN CLEAR
WITH WHAT THE PRESIDENT AND OUR
ADMINISTRATION HAVE WITHIN OUR
TOOLKIT TO DO.
AND SO FAR, THAT IS WHAT WE HAVE
BEEN PURSUING.
>> YOU WERE A SENATOR WITH
NOW-JUSTICES GORSUCH AND
KAVANAUGH TESTIFIED UPON MANY
ISSUES, INCLUDING ROE AT THEIR
CONFIRMATION HEARINGS.
NOW, KAVANAUGH CALLED IT
PRECEDENT UNPRECEDENT.
AT THAT PARTICULAR HEARING, YOU
WERE THERE.
SOME SENATORS SAY THEY
INTENTIONALLY MISLED THE PUBLIC
AND THE DONE GUESS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I NEVER BELIEVED THEM.
I DIDN'T BELIEVE THEM.
THAT'S WHY I VOTED AGAINST THEM.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT THERE IS
ANYTHING TO BE DONE NOW?
I MEAN, THERE IS NO -- THEY WERE
UNDER AGENT.
>> I THINK THAT -- LISTEN --
IT -- IT WAS CLEAR TO ME WHEN I
WAS SITTING IN THE CHAIR A
MEMBER OF THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE, THAT THEY WERE --
THEY WERE VERY LIKELY TO DO WHAT
THEY JUST DID.
THAT WAS MY PERSPECTIVE.
THAT WAS MY OPINION.
AND THAT'S WHY I VOTED LIKE I
DID IT.
>> BIG PICTURE.
DO YOU WORRY ABOUT TWO AMERICAS
NOW?
BECAUSE OF THE PATCHWORK OF
DIFFERENT STATES HAVING
DIFFERENT LAWS NOW THAT ROE v.
WADE IS NO LONGER LAW OF THE
LAND.
>> I DON'T BELIEVE WE HAVE TWO
AMERICAS.
I BELIEVE THAT WHEN YOU LOOK AT
AT ISSUE, FOR EXAMPLE, LIKE
ABORTION AND ROE, MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS SUPPORT RIGHT OF
AMERICAN TO MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT
HER BODY.
UM, WHEN YOU LOOK AT SOMETHING
LIKE THE ISSUE OF THE NEED FOR
REASONABLE GUN-SAFETY LAWS.
THE MAJORITY OF PEOPLE,
INCLUDING UNWITH OF THE NUMBERS
I HAVE SEEN THE MAJORITY OF GUN
OWNERS AGREE WE SHOULD HAVE
REASONABLE GUN-SAFETY LAWS.
SO I DON'T KNOW BUY INTO THE
IDEA THAT WE HAVE TWO AMERICAS.
WHAT DOES CONCERN ME IS THAT THE
RHETORIC YOU SEE THAT -- AMONG
CERTAIN ELECTED OFFICIALS CAN
ACTUALLY NOT REPRESENTATIVE OF
WHERE THE PEOPLE ACTUALLY ARE.
AND WE NEED TO LISTEN TO WHERE
THE PEOPLE ACTUALLY ARE.
THE VAST MAJORITY PEOPLE I THINK
HAVE SO MUCH MORE IN COMMON HAN
THAN WHAT SEPARATES THEM AND
THEY WANT US TO LEAD IN A WAY
THAT IS REFLECTIVE OF THEIR --
THEIR DAILY NEEDS AND THEIR
PRIORITIES.
SO, FOR EXAMPLE, SUPPORTING
PARENTS WITH A TAX CUT.
FOR CHILDCARE EXPENSES, WHICH WE
HAVE AEN AS ADMINISTRATION.
EXTENDING THE CHILD TAX AS WE
IT, IN THE FIRST YEAR, WE
BROUGHT DOWN CHILD POVERTY BY
ALMOST HALF DOING THE WORK OF
SAYING WE ARE GOING TO FOCUS ON
AN ISSUE LIKE MATERNAL MORTALITY
BECAUSE BLACK WOMEN, NATIVE
WOMEN, ARE ALMOST DWAULLY
IMPACTED IN TERMS OF DISPARITIES
OF OUTCOMES.
>> I WANT ASK TO YOU ABOUT THE
ECONOMY.
>> YEAH.
>> THERE IS A LOT OF ANXIETY
ABOUT THE ECONOMY.
WALLETSWELL BEING HURT RIGHT
NOW.
GAS PRICES AS YOU KNOW, ARE
STILL NEAR ABOUT $5 A GALLON.
THE PRESIDENT SAID HE WANTED A
GAS-TAX HOLIDAY.
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE IT'S GOING
ANYWHERE CONGRESS.
WHAT ELSE IS IN YOUR TOOLBOX?
IS THERE ANYTHING ELSE YOU CAN
DO TO HELP BRING DOWN THE COST
OF GAS?
>> LET'S JUST SAY, FIRST OF ALL,
THIS IS A VERY REAL ISSUE AND WE
HAVE TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
AND IT'S ONE OF OUR HIGHEST
PRIORITIES AS AN ADMINISTRATION.
SO, THERE IS THE PIECE THAT IS
ABOUT GAS AND BRINGING DOWN THE
COST OF GAS, IN WHICH LARGE PART
EXPLODED TALKING AS HE HAS BEEN
TO BRING ALLIES AND PARTNERS
TOGETHER OH SO WE CAN HAVE A
COMMON DEFENSE AROUND HA WE
BELIEVE TO BE DEMOCRATIC
PRINCIPLES, AROUND SOVEREIGNTY
AND TERRITORIAL INTEGRITY.
FOR EXAMPLE, BRINGING DOWN THE
COST OF PRESCRIPTION DRUGS.
ONE OF WE ARE FIGHTING TO SAY
SOMETHING LIKE INSULIN SHOULD
COST NO MORE THAN $35 A MONTH.
WE ARE FIGHTING TO SAY THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE AFFORDABLE CHILDCARE
SO THAT FAMILIES -- WORKING
FAMILIES SHOULDN'T PAY MORE THAN
7% OF THEIR INCOME IN CHILDCARE.
>> BUT YOU HAVE FIGHTING FOR
THAT WINCE DAY ONE BUT NOW IP
INFLATION IS REALLY HIGH.
THE ADMINISTRATION SAID THEY
WEREN'T THAT WORRIED ABOUT
THE -- ABOUT INFLATION.
AND THEN, THAT CHANGED.
>> I THINK THAT THERE CAN BE NO
HIGHER PRIORITY THAN WHAT WE
HAVE BEEN CLEAR IS OUR HIGHEST
PRIORITY, WHICH IS BRINGING DOWN
THE COST AND PRICES AS SOON AS
WE CAN.
>> JUST WANT TO ASK YOU QUICKLY
ABOUT JANUARY 6th.
>> OKAY.
>> YOU ARE A PROSECUTOR.
>> YEAH.
>> BY TRAINING AND BY LOTS OF
EXPERIENCE.
BASED ON THE EVIDENCE PRESENTED
SO FAR IN THE JANUARY-6th
HEARINGS, WOULD YOU BRING
CHARGES AGAINST FORMER-PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP?
>> AS A FORMER PROSECUTOR, I
NEVER COMMENT ON A PROSECUTOR'S
CASE.
>> MIKE PENCE, HAS YOUR OPINION
OF HIM CHANGED?
>> EL, I THINK HE DID HIS JOB
THAT DAY AND I COMMEND HIM FOR
THAT BECAUSE CLEARLY, IT WAS
UNDER EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT HE SHOULD NOT
HAVE HAD TO FACE.
AND I COMMEND HIM FOR HAVING THE
COURAGE TO -- TO DO HIS JOB.
>> LAST QUESTION.
I KNOW WE ARE OUT OF TIME.
YOUR FRIEND, THE CONGRESSMAN JIM
CLIE BURN SAID IF PRESIDENT
BIDEN DOESN'T SEEK RE-ELECTION,
YOU WOULD BE FIRST ON HIS LIST
IN 2024.
HAVE YOU TALKED TO PRESIDENT
BIDEN ABOUT RE-ELECTION?
AND WHAT DID YOU SAY TO
CONGRESSMAN CLYBURN.
>> JOE BIDEN IS RUNNING FOR
RE